the galaxy tab s7 plus is part of
samsung's newest lineup of 2020 products
and for what this tablet has to offer it
looks like it's said to be the apple
ipad's biggest competitor yet what's up
everybody zaki here from geek culture
and this is the first look at the
samsung galaxy tab s7 plus it's
basically the beefed up older brother of
the samsung galaxy s20 ultra sporting
key similarities on which we will touch
on later it is a 12.4 inch tablet
running on android 10 with one ui being
samsung's proprietary user interface
so let's touch on some of the tap s7
plus hardware specs before we really get
into what's going on with this tablet
it is only 5.7 millimeters thick and
weighs about 575 grams
it is actually surprisingly a lot
lighter than it looks
and the tablet is well balanced when you
hold it it doesn't feel as big as how
other 12 inch tablets usually feel
it comes in three color options the
mystic bronze mystic silver and the
mystic black which we have here
it also has a nice brushed metal finish
with an overall curvature design which
adds a sleek and modern aesthetic to the
tablet a unique feature that sets the s7
plus apart is how samsung has oriented
the tablet to be used in landscape mode
rather than the usual portrait
orientation
samsung has repositioned its front
camera from the top of the tablet to the
center of the tap s7 long edge
allowing users to hold video calls
without the awkward 10 to 16 crop
portrait thing that we see in phones the
screen on the s7 plus is gorgeous
sporting samsung's own super amoled
120hz touchscreen display with a
resolution of 2800x1752
the aspect ratio of 16x10 is nice and
comfortable with plenty of real estate
to do marking of documents or even
creative work
with the huge display screen sharing
with two or even three apps side by side
doesn't feel cramped up at all
like the galaxy s20 ultra this is one of
the best looking displays we've seen on
an android tablet
the colors are vibrant and the
brightness can be ramped up for outdoor
use
the s7 plus also boasts stereo quad
speakers located on both the left and
right side of the tablet
the audio produced by the speakers are
loud enough to be hurt even in noisy
places
[Music]
in terms of input and output the tablet
has a usbc for data transfer and quick
charging as well as a sim card and
microsd tray for the wi-fi and cellular
version
it also comes with a fingerprint on
display for added security allowing
users to sign in quickly with a simple
tab of the screen
the biometrics is pretty straightforward
and easy to set up
unlike most fingerprint scanners which
requires a few tries the tablet is
surprisingly responsive and works
successfully every time we try to unlock
the tablet with it along the back is
where you find the camera modules for
the step 7 along with another magnetic
strip for the s pen to snap onto and
charge speaking of the s pen its new and
improved redesign is slightly weightier
and will also come with improved
functionality and faster response time
of 9 milliseconds
so users will have a better time using
it for drawing marking documents and the
like
the s-pen also has air actions which
lets you control the tap s7 plus such as
taking selfies control presentations
play and pause music and movies without
having to actually touch the screen
moving on to the cameras at the rear we
have a 13 megapixel main camera with an
additional 5 megapixel ultra wide and an
led flash module while the front of the
tablet carries an 8 megapixel camera
both cameras are decent for capturing
enough details for any casual everyday
photo taking and even has 4k video
recording capabilities as a bonus with
its wireless deck support which i've
been using most of the time it
essentially turns your tap s7 plus into
a desktop-like experience
samsung also provides its own book cover
keyboard
it comes in two parts the back
protective cover with a pocket for the s
pen
and of course the keyboard with a
trackpad
setting it up is easy with the bottom of
the back cover being able to hinge out
making it easy to conform to your
preferred setting
it is unfortunate though that while
using it on our lap
we noticed that the keyboard proved to
be a little too long for us and we
decided to just use the tablet without
the keyboard instead the trackpad itself
has good clickability and multi-finger
gestures are supported on the touchpad
the keyboard feels great with a nice
tactile feel function buttons are also
fully utilized here for the tablet
allowing you to increase and decrease
brightness volume take a screenshot and
the search
the tablet comes with a solid battery
life with a capacity of 1090 milliamps
per hour
it easily give us 14 to 15 hours of
productivity which is more than a full
day
and folks will get the 15 watt travel
charger out of the box
again for a 12 inch android tablet
samsung has done an amazing job in
balancing the pc like experience with
the ethos of a tablet now some folks may
not exactly want that kind of
flexibility but samsung has definitely
made a huge step in improving their
tablets inside out the s7 plus will come
with up to eight gigabytes of ram and
256 gigabytes of storage with a micro sd
slot that likes to expand its memory by
up to one terabytes the s7 and s7 plus
will be available on the 21st of august
2020 prices start from 998 singapore
dollars and goes all the way up to 1798
singapore dollars for the 5g ready and
top of the line specs that we have here
for more details on the samsung galaxy
tab s7 plus do check out our full review
link in the description below and if you
like what you see don't forget to smash
that like button so that other geeks can
get a chance to watch this video and if
you haven't already do consider
subscribing and let us know in the
comments below what do you think about
the galaxy tab s7 plus until then this
is zeki signing off
[Music]